[Musique]
le corps de robert boulin a été retrouvé
ce matin vers 9h dans un étang de la
forêt de rambouillet désir soir des
recherches avaient été lancées car un
des collaborateurs de robert boulin
avait retrouvés dans le bureau du
ministre un message écrit de sa main
précisant son intention de mettre fin à
ses jours en forêt de rambouillet
monsieur goulet est arrivé par ce chemin
volant de sa 305 jus sont au bord de
l'étang rompu située en forêt de
rambouillet c'est un lieu qu'il
connaissait bien pour l'avoir parcouru à
cheval il ya plusieurs années
après avoir rédigé un bref message
d'adieu à sa famille au dos duquel il
précisait que les clés de sa voiture
était dans la poche arrière de son
pantalon il a semble-t-il absorbé des
barbituriques fermer les portes hier de
sa voiture à clef puis s'est avancé vers
l'étang au centre duquel les gendarmes
l'ont retrouvé ce matin après plus de
trois heures de recherches le corps de
monsieur moulin se trouvait à cinq
mètres du rivage
repêché par les pompiers il était
ensuite transportés à bord d'un
hélicoptère vers l'institut médico légal
[Musique]